how does this help me well if i now
return back to my original question
and i'm going to grab it from this point
here
i would say what i'm going to do is i'm
going to use this
to simplify what's going on with all of
my arguments and that kind of thing so
maybe i should actually
point out that i am doing a different
line of argument now so i'm going to say
return to the question because i've now
established that foundational knowledge
which i mentioned we're going to need
this is the equation that represents the
set of points that i'm after so
how do i get this into a form so that i
can use this knowledge here
well i said that this was in rectangular
form
that was half true you can see there's
the imaginary component there's a real
component flying around there
but z because it's just written as z
it's not in any
that complex number is not in any form
at the moment so i could write that as
like e to the i theta or something like
that or
um cos theta plus i sine theta i'm going
to write it in rectangular form though
because
rectangular form is cartesian form and
i'm trying to get to a cartesian
equation all right so here's what i'm
going to do i'm going to say
if z is equal to i'm going to write this
as not a plus
b but x plus i y because i want to end
up with an equation that relates
x's and y's together that'll mean about
cartesian equation okay
if z equals x i y i can just do a
substitution everywhere i saw z
i'm going to write x plus i y so that
gives me this arg of
x plus i y plus i
equals x plus i y
minus 3. okay now this is progress
now we really can get towards
rectangular form
because i just want a real component an
imaginary component right
so to do that on the left hand side
there's not much work required
the only in real part is just the x so
i'll leave that out the front
in fact i'll i'll go one better and i
will what did i use before i used orange
for the real part
so i'm going to go write that like so
and then here comes the imaginary part
now i'll factor out an i
and then when you think about well when
i factor out the eye of this what do i
end up with you can see you're going to
have
y lots of i and then one extra lot
of i so this is just my
you know rewriting this line above just
to really separate out the real
component
and the imaginary component okay so far
so good let's do the same thing to the
right hand side so i have the argument
here
and this time to get the real component
separated out you can see
both this x and this minus three they're
both real
so i'm going to include them both here x
minus 3
and then my imaginary component will
just be
y all right so
how does this help me well i now have
this in a form that looks
exactly like this you can see i've got
the argument of
the uh rectangular form of complex
number the cartesian form okay
now in order to sort of tease out all of
this and to turn into much something
much
simpler all i need to do is take tan
of both sides right if these two angles
that's what arguments are they're just
angles right
if these two arguments really are equal
then
10 of those arguments will also be equal
so i'm going to take tan of both sides
when i do that tan of everything you can
see
here this is going to be a rather long
line but we'll do our best
tan of this angle
will equal tan of this angle
i'm going to use this result that we saw
up here to then get rid of all of the
tens and the arguments i'm just going to
get x's and y's
and some other constants because that's
what i'm after a cartesian equation
right so all i need to do is say what's
the imaginary part
what's the real part and then i just
take the quotient right so let's have a
go
on the left-hand side the imaginary
component is y plus
1 and then i divide that by my real
component which is just
x so this you can see this is
b over a it's just that this is my
particular value of b this is my
particular value of a
so far so good what do i get on the
right hand side well
the imaginary component is just y
and then my real component will be x
minus 3.
so this is really good from something
that looked very intimidating and
terrible before
um you have um made things worse but
then substantially made things better
because now i have something
that is all just x's and y's there's not
even any eyes flying about there's just
some simple
real numbers that i can deal with okay
so some of you might be thinking
what's the big deal like this does sound
like it's better than trying to draw a
graph and
you know intuit your way through it um
using some kind of insight that maybe
might be hard to access
well things do look nice right now but i
have to give you a caution
i want you to notice that um this set of
um
this equation that i have here right
there rational functions as it were
something divided by something something
divided by something now in a minute i'm
going to cross multiply and i'm going to
get rid of all those fractions
but in their present form and this is
very important the fractions
have denominators that kind of mean
there are discontinuities
in whatever this function is going to be
equal to if you have a look at the
denominators
you can see x sorry yeah i'll keep that
x can't be 0 from this
and x can't be 3 from this so the
discontinuities that i notice
are that x can't equal 0
and x can't equal 3. now this is really
important because i have to do more than
just
exclude 0 and 3 from my solution when i
get it at the end
in fact what's going on is that um when
there's a discontinuity
the thing breaks and can behave very
differently which you'll see in a second
connect back to the uh the graph we
already know should be answer this which
we saw at the beginning of the question
so i'm going to note those
discontinuities and once i've simplified
out this equation we're going to explore
the implications of those right
so um let's go ahead and cross multiply
like
promised so what i've got on the left
hand side is
y plus 1 x minus three that's that cross
multiplication and then the right hand
side it's just
x y all right let's expand this thing on
the left hand side so
i will multiply y by both terms first
that gives me x y
minus three y and then i'm going to
multiply everything by 1. so that gives
me plus
x minus 3. my xy is still hanging out
there
you can see there's an xy term on both
sides which we can eliminate so that's
nice if i rearrange a teeny bit
by adding 3y to both sides and then
swapping the sides of the equation you
land here
and then lastly just because um this is
my favorite form for an
equation of a straight line i'm going to
divide both sides by 3 which gives me
this in
slope gradient so i have an equation
i have a cartesian equation it's
marvelously simple i know you were
probably panicking we got to this point
here
and even this didn't look very good in
particular but as soon as you saw that x
y can't come out i hope you thought ah
thank goodness this is going to be
something lovely
but we have these discontinuities to
deal with right
now like i mentioned before like i
alluded to these discontinuities they do
more
than just punch holes in the graph that
we're after
they in fact break our graph into three
separate
regions or three separate cases um if
you want to think about this way
if you want to think about all the
potential x values and of course there
are y values that correspond to this
all the potential x values now sort of
sit in one of three regions
um you've got zero and three where you
have discontinuities
and then you've got this section over
here where x is
less than zero we want to work out
what's happening over there does that
part of the graph satisfy
our equation or not you've got this
section in here between
uh 0 and 3 and then you've lastly got
this section here
where x is greater than 3. this is the
key shortcoming
of the algebraic technique because we
have never appealed to a graph at any
point
i can't just look at the graph and say
oh it can't
possibly be you know you can't have a
point there because it wouldn't satisfy
the geometric reasoning that we've used
to come up with this line you just have
to plow through the algebra we have to
test a spot in each one of these
regions to determine whether um you know
it actually satisfies the equation or
not uh this equation up here
which is just one line after the one we
started with okay